as the noon deadline passed the normally
bustling Sean Solis se was almost
deserted the famous shops and pavement
cafes of Paris shuttered by orders of
the French president only essential
movement is allowed now and
non-essential activity is being punished
with a fine of more than fifty dollars
across France 100 thousand extra police
are enforcing a lockdown which extends
beyond the streets and into the home of
every citizen what would an example
conclude to give you some examples a
family lunch dinner with friends a
football game with friends a game of
cards all of that which might not
normally seem important is now forbidden
not just discouraged but forbidden let's
not downplay it each one of those
meetings is a moment when the virus can
be transmitted the North Italian city of
Brescia is in Lombardy epicenter of
Europe's covert 19 outbreak the grave
concern across Europe stems from the
hard lessons being learned here what is
really shocking something we had not
been able to forecast and brought us to
our knees is how quickly the epidemic
spreads within two weeks now three weeks
since the beginning of the epidemic we
put a total of 1,200 patients in
Lombardy in intensive care and so the
freedom of movement enjoyed by Europeans
for decades has abruptly ended this was
the traffic jam at the franca Swiss
border a four-hour queue affecting even
essential workers like this nurse Don
Conoco leg music don't you see our
patients are waiting for us our
colleagues are also waiting for us these
are still human beings they're in their
beds they're waiting for blood tests
they're waiting for us to feed them and
here we go we are stuck the e use
external borders are being shut to a ban
imposed on entry for non EU citizens for
the next 30 days relaxing the ease
internal borders though is now an
imperative we have a lot of traffic jam
of lorries transporting goods the flow
of goods has to be Swift
we need these goods for the functioning
of the internal market for the moment at
least the UK is resisting pressure to
lock down its citizens people have been
urged to
avoid bars restaurants and leisure
venues and work from home where possible
the government is offering 400 billion
dollars of loan guarantees to support
affected businesses and the Prime
Minister has appealed for national unity
this enemy can be deadly but it is also
beatable and we know how to beat it and
we know that if as a country we follow
the scientific advice that is now being
given we know that we will beat it but
the prospect of a compulsory lockdown is
looming Italy with more than 2000
coronavirus deaths is the worst affected
country outside of China and with more
than 3,000 new infections in Italy every
day the burden on hospital capacity is
almost overwhelming but the rate of
infection has slowed slightly in the
Lombardy region epicenter of the
country's outbreak there at least there
is a faintest glimmer that the
quarantine measures are starting to show
results
Paul Brennan al-jazeera